so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dobiziola
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast I am here with my
co-host Marty O'Neill what's up guys
what's up we just realized two seconds
ago this is the last episode of the Year
this is it
it's been a really good year thank you
guys so much for everything
um yeah last episode of the Year all
right really odd to say but let's get
straight into it guys this is it last
episode of the Year we're at episode
what 96 97. I can do about a little more
than half a pull-up
I'm getting there I know we said but yo
I didn't forget don't think I forgot I
have a great memory
I'm getting there I'm getting there so
um that is being said with that being
said season three you know how we ended
at the end of the year real quick update
our first episode we shoot with our new
studio is middle of January
so we're going to let this ride until
episode 100. how crazy that our season
two ends episode 100. it's gonna be
right around there we're gonna see how
it goes probably 99. I'm not sure but
we're gonna hit you guys with some epic
guess the second we start let's keep
Underground
that's some pretty cool guests Kevin
okay guys yeah new studio
knew everything New Year everything's
looking up all right everything's
looking up today Marty and I were
thinking yo it's real it's Christmas
time how are we gonna get a guest in
time
so we said let's just do our own let's
just do a Christmas and then we realize
it's the last one of the year so this
one's going to be the Christmas story
good we got some great Vibes going down
at the studio oh today's today's a great
day
we're just over the course of two years
we learned let's just let it happen
before we start talking about it all
right let's just let it happen exactly
but mission accomplished guys in terms
of what we set out for and how we had to
grow the show and all that so thank you
again thank you guys I literally said
can you believe people watch us enough
that we bought these lights yeah we said
that seconds ago like wow what a good
run we've had so awesome yeah it's just
me and you oh we have a team starting
next month
things you're about to get to where
people go wow The Fan Experience is
about to go way up I'm excited guys all
right we're we're very oh
look at this I already just gave me this
Cypress Hill sweater it's got joints on
the arm let's go get out shut up be real
foreign
that was a trip that was awesome shout
out to be real for that
um so guys we're gonna get straight into
this right now right away we're gonna
hit it hard
um a couple of these I'm just gonna
touch on because we might have talked
about them before but we're gonna go
straight into it and we've talked about
it during the season
the one thing that makes Story Time
immersive is the camera I lock like
you're looking at talking to you
this season since Marty's been here
we've been talking to each other
and I'm like yo you know what I mean you
know what I mean it's almost like you're
left out of the conversation so I gotta
start turning to the camera again
Marty's gonna do the same we're trying
to remind ourselves so we're gonna get
into this a couple stories real quick
and then we have Epic News Christmas
giveaway stuff we just wanted to say
thank you I was shocked when I realized
we were giving away to yeah yeah all
right I wasn't shot but more like oh
yeah [ __ ] you about to be happy so stick
around okay so this is what we're gonna
do guys I'm gonna get right into it this
is Christmas we're gonna lead you from
the little league and up Marty hasn't
told me any of his what he's got so it's
all it's all going to be news to me here
we go guys let's start this off
Christmas Story Time here we go here we
go guys you guys already know I started
off my life first seven years I was
violently sick with the flu I think we
talked about this recently super sick
with the flu so I had uh I can remember
my hallucinations the one with the witch
and the bear circling around my head
like a cartoon and they were screaming
when they got closer I heard him louder
and they would go away and then I heard
him louder don't understand and you guys
have heard it before I saw Santa Claus
come in I thought it was hallucinating I
think it was my grandpa drunk as hell
from a Christmas party my grandma was
just beating the [ __ ] out of him with
something tell him to get out he's
asleep and I think my grandma's kicking
my grandpa out so you've heard that
story on here so let it travel into yes
sick for several years violently
violently sick
spinning shakes cold throw up everything
you can think of
why I don't remember my mom once it was
always my grandma Dolores taking care of
me
so for this first seven years my mom was
like oh he's sick take him so I don't
know if that's true mom you're in the
chat for sure so you let me know you're
saying just by coincidence I don't ever
remember her once it's always my grandma
taking care of I was eating crackers
drinking Sprite and eating chicken
little stupid [ __ ] shaking watching
prices Right with Bob Barker every year
around mid-December you start going down
every single year until I can remember
like the fourth grade I didn't get sick
on Chris I wasn't like throwing up and
sick while everybody's doing prep like I
was sick I remember being sick and um
brings me into the the Christmases that
I can remember all right this is a story
I'm not gonna put you on blast you dick
one of my best homies growing up here we
go you guys know I grew up mad poor you
guys know that if I didn't have my
Grandma Grace or my grandma Dolores well
mainly my grandma Dolores I wouldn't got
[ __ ] really as a kid and again my mom
was a child
getting off drugs trying to make it as a
single mom so I'm not going to put no
blame on her my dad barely got me [ __ ]
and if it was working so he was tweaking
too but he was working and uh
so here it is guys I remember I'm in the
sixth grade I think I've told you this
before I met this kid I walked into the
sixth grade the first day of sixth grade
you guys know this you guys are probably
sitting with the home real quick Miami
meet and greet I met a group of four
homies that have been best friends since
kindergarten all watch our [ __ ] all in
college they all came to meet and greet
that's awesome bro it was the I'm like
so wait you guys known each other since
kid and they're like yeah first grade
kindergarten what do most people have
friends like that I don't I don't know I
I really only have that's myself that'd
be so cool man
let us know in the comments yeah
lifelong friends that's so dope dude the
oldest friend I have is jeebus and I met
him the first day of ninth grade
you know I mean that's the longest like
friendship it was a little Preston too
but I don't chill with a little press
yeah but anyway
I walk in you guys know this feeling I
walk and I go it's a nice WrestleMania
shirt you got on
we're friends now he's like oh so who do
you like my stone cold he goes
yeah I like this white kid some like
poor ass little white kid poor ass
little Mexican kid I'm like all right
we're gonna white man can't jump except
except we both catch up and he was mad
good at basketball this is the same kid
that I said I smoked weed with his
cousin and that was the last time we
played basketball oh yeah this is the
guy yeah no sad yeah it was it still
makes me kind of sad
um so here we go back to the story
immersive back to the story here we go
so I am
it's Christmas time and you know you
stopped going to school like the 15th or
16th my homie doesn't live that far from
me we're both poor he hasn't lived that
far from me but he I will say this
I grew up without [ __ ] he grew up
without nothing this kid was like I can
only imagine he had like no shoes on as
a kid but his mom mad cool tweaker mad
awesome
not a good mom but a nice person
you know does that make sense totally
okay so uh he has a little sister and
it's and it's him I'm not gonna say his
name but anyway
I remember like yo this do you remember
when Razor scooters came out guys they
were like you got a scooter a Razor
scooter with the soft things on the
front the handles you could do the whole
whip you know what I mean like it had
the back break you step on that break oh
my grandma Dolores got me one
because she was awesome if I like I said
if I didn't have her meeting my sister
wouldn't had [ __ ]
so my grandma got me one and I remember
like my grandma gives me money my other
grandma gives me money for Christmas my
aunt will probably give me money
I as a kid you guys know I was
collecting dollars collecting chains
just turning in cans trying to because I
would like to want to buy something I
want to buy a Packers jacket you guys
remember that whole story so
I had like 110 bucks
and I remember like these Razor scooters
are like 140. and that was in like early
2000s they were taxing for a scooter but
I knew like yo I can't have a Razor
scooter and my homie not have a scooter
like I kind of like find a way to get
him a scooter I'm not about to ask my
poor ass mom like can you buy my friend
a present
she would have did it if she had the
money my mom was cool but
I remember I saved up all the money
it was right after Christmas break and
he didn't get [ __ ] for Christmas I was
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I saved up all my money I went
to the flea market and I bought him a
scooter and it wasn't a razor because I
couldn't afford it right it wasn't a
razor it was like some other brand but
it was red strips I'm like damn this
one's harder than mine he's gonna love
it
and you remember the screws that fold in
half you had to unlock and they opened
Razor scooters I remember this so
vividly guys I'm like working my ass off
trying to get more money at my grandma
Dolores and my grandma Grace's she would
like on Dust here's 50 cents but yeah
clean up the kitchen I'll give you a
dollar
like it was slave work like that who
cares I was doing it dusting all her
little paper weights she had everywhere
now I'm that guy with all my little
beads I was every time I see a bead with
something like man Grandma Dolores and I
get high with it but she just has it in
paperweights anyway I'm cleaning our
paper to give me some change we play gin
rummy and poker and I'm like grumpy
trying to bet like nickels we'd always
bet Nichols and she lost on purpose she
didn't give him like 30 cents like my
God but 30 cents in your hand all that
silver whoo turn into the machines when
Coinstar first came out I was crushing
it anyway I got like 120 bucks total
and I went and bought this full of
scooter I was so Juiced like overly
excited I like buying [ __ ] for people
more than I like getting stuff because I
don't really like having hella [ __ ] Plus
it's cool I liked it I like that I like
doing that
I remember I get I went to school
because I hadn't seen them all break he
went to his dad's or something his dad
was even worse but he went to his dad's
out of town
and I walked into school and I saw him
and I walked up I'm like this is yours
and he looked at me like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
I'm like that's yours fool and like I
could see his face like oh my God thank
you and then he opened it up and our
teacher's like don't open that in class
I'm like ah eight seconds in ago so you
can't ride it I guess till after school
all right
not even done like two days later I
heard him talking [ __ ] about it
broke my heart bro I heard a secondary
through somebody else
he was bummed because it wasn't a Razor
scooter
that's the end of the story I was so you
still like friends I was friends with
him but I was just like bro damn [ __ ]
my bad [ __ ] I never brought it up but I
felt like
damn
all right you [ __ ] imagine a kid
getting you a gift oh bro we were the
same man he's older than I am and it was
on tear with your top should you wanted
like that was whoa I could have saved
that money
I never bought a kid a gift it was my
homie though and I knew how poor that
fool was but I remember thinking like
oh
I feel stupid I never felt that like
embarrassment of like oh my bad that's
the first time I experienced that you
know but yeah that was the story
that's it can we let a joint
I ruined my whole [ __ ] Christmas hype
I was so hyped to give him that present
bro did you have friends that were like
balling out of control yeah that was
always disheartening I never got bummed
I always win
I get old enough bro and I don't have
kids I can't wait to get money and buy
them [ __ ] that's why I always never want
to have a kid like I can't dude I don't
want to be poor with a kid um there was
this one kid I'll say his name [ __ ] you
is Kate named Matt it's Asian kid named
Matt he would not let you leave the
conversation without letting you know
what he had
like we went to the poor school and this
fool was hand in the pocket yeah you
know my father he bought me the new Xbox
like
oh you live in a bedroom you have you
share a room oh
how he was like he always bummed me out
like I really hate Matt bro he's such a
dick about it he would always oh yeah
your parents yeah how much they make
like you know where you telling you live
in you're like one of six fools with
parents snobby I've never got such an
[ __ ] about it dude if you live
directly next to the neighborhood okay
he's in the good side of town if you go
to the same Walmart or the same Target
as these people that you're all being
judgy against you guys are all in the
same [ __ ] spot not even that full
[ __ ] four foot tall little tiny kid I
just wanted to pop him on the head but I
never got mad at kids having money
that's awesome like I remember I went to
my first this kid cody I went to his
house and his dad like they recycle they
do this and I walked into a school
project I'm like this is your room Cody
yeah yeah me and my dad like
what
if they had like a three bedroom house I
know a lot of people out there like bro
what like
that's very big you know I mean in a
town that has nothing I just remember
like certain friends like yo you you got
one for Christmas
oh my
God you know I never got salty I just
saw there was all the only time I did
was when those kids I'd be like dude I
hate that kid if I got something sick of
like oh yeah my grandma got me something
cool mm-hmm yeah yeah and I kept it
under wraps like I gotta just sit here
and brag we're all poor bro what if you
got nothing
you know what I mean like that's what
that's why I don't really brag about
[ __ ] because I always have that in my
head of like what if this was doing real
bad you don't want to it's not as
because I remember for example I had
homies that were balling out of control
and I was struggling out of my ass off
like three years ago
I never got salty I never went yeah
before you spending money like an idiot
it's your money I was like good [ __ ] one
day watch yeah I pulled up my Honda my
homie got his Lambo I went oh my God I'm
so happy right now I can't believe you
got it like by the way my car is your
wheels
well you kept like when you were doing
the house Vlog you kept kind of
qualifying each little different segment
with that you know I mean like kind of
explaining to people oh yeah yeah yeah
cause
the way I see it's more of like
nothing's changing bro I just oh my gosh
my [ __ ] I've always like damn I can't
afford that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
you're supposed to look at it and be
like damn this is possible I know this
[ __ ] is one of us yeah that's
how I feel it's fuel yeah that's how I
feel when I see my home he's like that
was my
I'm gonna get there like good [ __ ]
I didn't have any examples of anybody
that had ever did it that I knew that
like how I wanted to do it so there's
nobody to look at
you know but like for us now it's like
people start seeing you know our whole
team become successful like I see
whatever my homies do [ __ ] I'm like wow
now I'm over motivated you know I think
that's a great circle of friends to have
of course like nobody's salty just like
oh my God good [ __ ] I can't wait to get
mine that was we were talking about this
the other day that's super super
important and it was like a big section
in this new David Goggins book I just
listened to we just finished up a second
book never finished better than the
first one uh who's in your Foxhole like
you sign up for this fight who's in
there fighting with you are they
fighting with you and supporting you or
are they kind of like or are they not
because it takes a real specific
personality type to really be with you
for that long-term fight that you sign
up for and it's an energy and vibrations
if you guys can see your friend smiling
being happy for you but you can see the
smiles like you don't look stoked for me
you got to cut them off bro I know how
many rappers go I had cut off my best
friend but because you came up and they
got butt hurt yeah and that and like
what they don't talk about is when you
do do that like
that [ __ ] might not ever really go away
like that might [ __ ] with you forever
like these are all those memes about you
gotta just cut people off that are you
know still think about them that might
yeah I saw Benny said like that might
leave a scar like you might have to do
it that [ __ ] might be a giant scar that
you have though oh yeah big time it's
just the certain level of person you
needed around you it doesn't matter if
your friend makes five dollars a year as
long as your homies on that different
level that you're at money never
mattered I chilled with all my rich ass
homies before I had a dollar
nothing ever changed now it's just like
yo oh my God you got yeah you're like
now I'm like oh my god it works
it took 11 years but it worked
I don't know I I know we're going on no
I'm horrible at checking in with people
I don't I heard from one of my main
homeboys they went homeboys the other
day
and it's it's nice to just even if like
you know we don't have any business
together but just to get that back up
that affirmation that like you know me
or just that little you know like yeah
you're doing the right thing you're
going the right direction a little
affirmation from somebody that really
knows he goes a long way yeah [ __ ] yeah
it does it does truly it's a
it's good to have around man
it's cool I don't I dude I have this
many friends like
yeah and like two of them I see every
day or I see once a week man that's why
I see you more than 90 of my home he's
gonna see you once a week all my friends
are busy and they got I'm the only one
without kittens bro only on me basically
out here without no kids how long you
see this going without kids five more
years four
solid I got time bro I got time
and I'm so busy
that's when you're really kind of like
that's a good time to have kids yeah
dude I'll be [ __ ] 50 when they're 15
type [ __ ] 51 52 I'm with it I'll be a
Rogan oh yeah my kids graduating high
school we'll still be doing the show
guys we'll still be here so I know we're
getting off on the [ __ ] but yeah
um
[ __ ] it's not a razor what an
[ __ ]
um okay
oh
[Laughter]
oh I hate you so much
oh my God okay on to this next real
quick story
ready here we go I am
10 maybe 11 years old I'm 10 actually no
11 11 yeah 11.
and you guys heard my uncle John many
times right this is the year right after
my aunt started dating I met my uncle
John at George Brown gym in Merced which
is now like In-Shape City
that he had big jobs
hair chops look like Sabretooth and I
met him I was going into the gym because
I was in football I was going to the gym
with my mom's I was [ __ ] fat kid
go to the gym I'm in Miami pepper she'd
walk up with this weird goofy little
white guy
and he has these chops that go nice to
meet you she goes oh my name is John I
go you look like Sabertooth he goes
thanks and I was like I [ __ ] with that
guy thanks I was like oh not like who is
that like he was like oh thanks I'm like
oh I [ __ ] with you dude and that's how I
met my uncle John right so we're living
together on Queen Circle that's where we
have my me my mom my stepdad the jail
jailbird my sister is the first time we
had our own rooms that that house the
same place where my sister threw knives
and tried to kill me and try to stab me
same house same house where I Swanton
bombed and almost broke my neck I
thought I was paralyzed and then my mom
went to work so I stayed there for like
two hours and I didn't move and then I
started moving my legs I thought I broke
my neck it hurt I just felt and I
couldn't move and I was just hearing
that house on a table no I Swanton bomb
off the couch onto some cushions and the
cushion there was a gap and I landed on
my top of my head and I heard and I just
didn't move I felt pain and hell of heat
coming off my neck and I'm like don't
don't move don't move don't move I was
just sitting there crying like tearing
because I couldn't move I tried to move
my arms but it hurt my whole back I'm
like oh my God I broke my neck anyway
that house so we're on Queen Circle just
chilling right we're in Queen Circle uh
we live there you know like I said my
step Dad my mom me Shireen and they
converted this the garage into a huge
room I didn't even know it used to be a
garage it's a badass room so my aunt
pepper rents that room for my mom
and she started dating that guy John and
he moved in so that's my uncle my uncle
John you know my aunt's boyfriend I
always call my aunt's boyfriend John
because he wasn't really my uncle yet so
this brings me the Christmas story we
have this on tape I know we have it I'll
find it for you I'll find the pictures
or something
Michael John very into video games super
into video games Grand Theft Auto he's
the one that showed me Grand Theft Auto
Michael John I walked in he was playing
Grand Theft Auto 2 where you're up top
looking down and the cars drive and
you're the top view that's what Grand
Theft Auto he showed Oh [ __ ] yeah and
then I walked in no no the first one I
saw was part three when you're in a when
you're in Liberty City and I saw him
walking and go what is this game he goes
It's called Grand Theft Auto
what do you do he goes whatever you want
and he pressed Circle and he punched a
lady
anyway what you can hear people just
watch this got in the car and like shut
up shut up I sat there and it's not my
favorite game of all time still I was 11
or 10 when he showed me I sat one
my mom was my aunt's boyfriend's tight
as hell and then he showed me the old
one he's like look this is what he used
to be but this is the first time you can
actually be a guy because you used to be
on top he was telling me all this [ __ ]
I'm like what oh my God I'm by the ocean
get in the car present Circle punching
[ __ ] everywhere and uh
I know a PlayStation it was his
PlayStation and I was so excited I'm
like yo my stepdad said he's gonna give
me a PlayStation oh it's coming it's
coming and then it was Christmas my
whole family's there my grandma my
grandma my aunts everyone my stepdad's
family
that he's adopted so his family is like
his adopted family that raised him kinda
they're Tweakers too oh God anyway we're
all there
and we're all doing Christmas I remember
there's a couple videos and pictures of
me my friend Eli badowski was there the
one that my stepdad scared his dad oh
yes sir oh and he ran off the cop yeah
that's the kid that was in my Christmas
he's anyway we have the pictures we're
all doing Christmas I get the
PlayStation 2 I lose my
the gray I remember the gray I'm looking
at like open is that the skinny one no
no PlayStation two not three okay the
regular old PS2 oh there was a skinny
version of two yeah the yellow memory
card came with a yellow memory card I'm
looking at like oh my God
they got it for me I couldn't believe it
I'm only saying this because it's such a
good memory all right everything's going
on my sister's doing stuff my my
stepdad's got like a shirt it was like
Ned Flanders
it's like the normal Christmas and then
I turn around
and I see my aunt pepper sitting and I'm
I think we have it on tape I'm positive
we have the pictures and I'm standing
I'm right here
I'm sitting opening it
and I look up at my aunt's right there
and I see my uncle John just bend down
and hit full [ __ ] proposed to my aunt
right then and there and my answer
started crying and [ __ ] and I'm looking
like so it's my uncle John now like all
right you're part of the family now hell
yeah you're trying to play [ __ ]
PlayStation after this like it was like
though one of those moments I remember
like
what a movie did he have a lot of
friends or did you just become his best
friend like that basically no he only
had two homies and they both they both
done but yeah he only had two homies I
was so quiet he won't talk to nobody
but he's allowed as funny as per person
ever [ __ ] screams he's never shuts
the [ __ ] up in the house yeah as soon as
we get outside he'd even eat at our
family [ __ ] functions he was like no
I'll eat later he was very like
I gotta get out of here I didn't know he
just wanted to go smoke [ __ ] weed
outside I didn't know he smoked weed I
was a kid I didn't know that I didn't
know that that's what he was doing
I didn't know and then uh when I turned
like 14 13 no 13 is the first time you
ever smoked weed with me
I remember see like would you consider
him like a heavy duty smoker like he was
oh yeah
yeah but when I started selling weed and
smoking weed he was like oh my God
you smoke a lot of women yeah yeah
then I started selling pounds well he
was gone when I started selling actual
weight and he got back from the Army and
I remember the day he got back from the
Army he walked into the
the first apartment and he was like
Thomas what the [ __ ]
your old connect like that guy sucks he
used to get it from this guy and I'm
like that fool's a [ __ ] there's one
person in life that I don't [ __ ] with
and I don't even know him that well
should he plug
he was my Uncle John's connect when he
used to work at Papa John's he would
bring him eighty dollars a pizza and
he'd give him a quarter
so it was cool and he was an awesome guy
he had a [ __ ] sick ass car one of the
white weed dudes in Mercedes here Uncle
John is the Original Pizza weed dude no
no he would trade it for weed gotcha he
would just worked at the pizza place so
when I was at Tanaya at sixth grade my
uncle John was the guy that brought the
pizza in for lunch because every lunch
they bring on pizza and sell them at
school like pieces of pizza for two two
dollars my uncle John would always be
the guy with the pizza like what's up
man
it was crazy
I just thought I was the coolest kid
ever like that's my uncle
and uh
he would sell he would make these pizzas
uh for this [ __ ] this [ __ ] Merced
this guy
and he would uh
give him John Weed my 80 sacks that's
what he always called I got a little 80
sack it was just a quarter of weed but
I'm saying did he find it humorous that
you then went on to become a pizza for
sure he thought it was hilarious and he
was there for that he came back when
that was oh no he he came back right
when it ended oh my God talking about
but when he came back from the Army he's
like Thomas what the [ __ ] oh that's a 30
pounds over he goes what the [ __ ]
because he saw a pound he goes Tommy
most we ever got was like you know half
zip of weed he ever got his life ever
seen gotcha and he goes Thomas what the
[ __ ] oh John
things are different
it's like your connect [ __ ] that fool I
was like what do you mean like [ __ ] him
like the biggest weed dealer in town he
comes back I'm like it's a [ __ ] and I'm
like saying that about him he's like
what the [ __ ] happened in town ago let
me break it down for you [ __ ] him
don't ever call him again type of [ __ ]
I'll give you the quick story it's
nothing new Christmas since we did the
Christmas story and that was it he
became my uncle let me get into this
next story real real real real quick
that's nothing to do with Christmas it's
a bonus story time all right and then
we're gonna get into the giveaways
boom you guys know all right his name is
not John the dealer my name the dealer
my from my dealers the story times got
it's one of my biggest stories I got a
couple million views on it people love
that episode I talked about all my weed
connects growing up and my friend Ryan
my homie that I talk about sometimes his
older brother was the man when it came
to wheat he was the when I there was no
one to look up to
when I saw this guy he was 19 his full
hat uh AMG
and like a hunter band stacked he had a
fur coat like he was like yo this kid's
19 years old he's the one getting the
packs he was [ __ ] with all the Bay
Area rappers I listened to like they
[ __ ] with him I'm like this is a
superstar and then I found out he was my
one of my best homie's older brother I'm
like shut the [ __ ] up that's your
brother like that fool he would come in
before I started selling heavy he would
come in and give his brothers like a QP
and I'm sitting there like one day I'm
gonna get like that where I can confront
someone like you
and now it's like a qpi smoke it
back down like whoa you fronted your
little brother
I've never I've never witnessed any sort
of fronting on that level and the end
Ethan his smallest brother he would
front him and uh so anyway back to what
I'm saying he is the man he's a white
kid I've never seen anybody freestyle
that hard in my life on top of
everything I heard him freestyle wanted
him to shut the [ __ ] up
it's been 25 minutes you're still going
goofy fun stuff funny goofy [ __ ] that
we're doing I'm like
how are you coming up with words that
rhyme that fast what is happening like
yo and you got the weed you're the
coolest guy I've ever seen ever
ever and he was talking about how he met
on nicotine games so we that's my
favorite rapper girl I'm like shut the
[ __ ] up you met on your neck and he
talked to you like you know as a kid
you're like these people are superstars
they're so far out of reached like bro
he's in Frisco
you know like it's just down the street
but back then I don't even have a car
like how am I gonna get Frisco my mom
will beat the [ __ ] out like so you know
I'm looking up at this full four years
all night whoa
damn I'm reading up on an house wow this
one's got 100 pounds
so anyway back to that story him my
dealer let's call him his name was John
in my dealer story time so
it's confusing this is called my dealer
my dealer right the guy that disappeared
this is before he disappeared obviously
this is when I first [ __ ] heard of
his ass then we became really [ __ ]
almost best homies and then he
disappeared it's really weird thinking
about that
really odd he's still missing so it's
like it's [ __ ] odd thinking about it
um anyway his best friend
was my Uncle John's connect
the guy that I in town knew like yo this
Fool's got the crazy car he's got the
fire that's the man and then I found out
about my dealer Ryan's older brother and
went oh he's the man he's fronting my
Uncle John's connect I didn't know like
I didn't know that so Uncle John's
always trading this weed to this guy
and he's cool and then I found out my
uncle John knows my idealer
I know it's so confusing
so my dealer Ryan's brother my Uncle
John's gets trades pizza for this dealer
that I thought was a man then I found
out about him found out he's a little
guy compared to him and they're best
friends so this is where it comes down
to let's say my dealer and his best
friend [ __ ]
this is what happened this is why my
homies [ __ ] life started going
downhill
then he got hooked on pills real bad
we've talked about it before then some
[ __ ] happened with some piece of [ __ ]
they disappeared I'm not gonna go any
further because I could also get shot
you know I mean like I'm not going to
talk about some open fit
what if some [ __ ] happened I don't know
what happened but I guarantee it's that
[ __ ] that did it I already know
but what am I gonna do
I don't know for sure I'm not a cop
he's missing it's been nine years so no
10 it's been a decade actually so anyway
um
my dealer and his best friend [ __ ]
they party their best friends since high
school like they're trapping together
they go to the bar
they go to the bar I know the story is
taking forever ready go back on my
actual storytelling skills Jesus Christ
they're going to the bar and my dealer
loves to get [ __ ] up at the bar he
loves doing he's [ __ ] around with
chicks talks a girl he's a 19 year old
with a [ __ ] hell of stacks of course
he's having fun his other homie same
same age they trap together they re-up
together he fronts in the sacks like on
some straight up
like Ace
paid in full [ __ ] like those are
brothers like their brothers
I remember the day it happened bro my
dealer they're at the bar this before
we're really good friends right we
became friends about six months after
this happened real good friends were
chilling together and he told me what's
going on he had a house a house fatter
than anybody's parents house he had a
house just him it's just him
like a six bedroom house in Merced five
bedroom house it's ridiculous as a kid
and he's dope as hell anyway his best
friend are at the bar and his best
friend [ __ ] says hey man I'm gonna
turn I'm gonna turn in like I'm tired as
hell it's midnight and my homie's like
what the hell you're a [ __ ] all right
I'll stay so my dealer is telling me
this story remember and he's like my
dealer and [ __ ] friend are at the
bar [ __ ] friend says hey I'm gonna
turn in he's like bro I'ma stay out and
drink [ __ ] that and he said like 15
minutes later my dealer was like my
friend's gone I'm going home I'm kind of
bored now he's gone what the [ __ ] he
says he goes home but he told [ __ ]
that I'm gonna stay so dick head's going
home I think nothing of it's my best
friend why why does he care I'ma stay
out
he says he goes home 15 minutes later
he's like you know I'm bored [ __ ] this
he says he goes home
and right when he goes home he's getting
into his bedroom and he just sees
someone busting him through his side
window
he says he sees like oh hell no she's
like I got my [ __ ]
machine gun yeah he got his Nerf gun
he's like I got my pit I got my [ __ ] I'm
like oh hell no I start going down
because he said he saw someone hit the
window on the side he's like are they
trying to get into my [ __ ] [ __ ] so he
said I'm going down the hallway to go to
my bedroom because he's like I know what
window they're going for if they're
gonna rob me they know where they
something's going on he's like [ __ ] that
he says he creeps to his window and
right when he does he sees someone's
like hands hitting the ground because
they're coming into the window
and he says he just pop pop eyes are
shooting in the air the full [ __ ]
just oh it backs out the car and backs
out the window starts dipping and he's
like you know what [ __ ] it so I start
shooting through my door my wall
like he's probably right there he's like
[ __ ] this fool like it's my house I'm
gonna shoot
and he says he's popping the wall like
because he's like oh it's gonna hit that
window boom he didn't want to kill the
man
but he didn't want to like
not shoot at him so he's like and that
dude was 20 feet away in his room he's
like the guy just backed up started
screaming backing out the window dipped
and he's like
I think he's just trying to put fear in
this man like oh my God I'm dodging
bullets yeah
my homie busts out his front door
to [ __ ] shoot the guy because he was
like [ __ ] it I'ma pop him once this is
[ __ ] someone's gonna what if he's
coming to kill me yeah he's telling me
this story six months later amped up
pissed and like sat at the world and
[ __ ] I'm like why is this fool so ant
about this story he's like I'm like [ __ ]
it you know what
I'm good and he's like I had him right
in my lawn and I went you know what
I'm good and he said as soon as he was
like I'm not gonna shoot him the guy
noticed he was at the door and went bro
bro bro it's me it's me and what's his
homie he was trying to [ __ ] gank all
his [ __ ] when he was at the bar that's
why he turned in early Jesus Christ he
said he took it off he's like oh yeah
and he's like he got into his knees like
bro and he was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me he's I just like teared up
and walked in the house
that was it good it was he was strapped
too the flat a [ __ ] gun on him hmm
the dude that was breaking him his best
homie had a pistol on him
bro you don't bring that unless you're
ready to use it and you know who lives
there it's your best friend you were
there smoking blunts all day with him
yeah no you came to Rob him and or if
something happens pop him
right so my homie's like I [ __ ] like
realize what happened and I just turned
and walked in my door
and then he went oh [ __ ] I got a hundred
piece here I just shot up my house [ __ ]
and then he said he ditched a gun he put
the uh peas in a little stash spot in
his house got on the roof and started
jumping roofs of the of the of the spot
there's been many times where I've been
in a party and I see him turn around he
jumped off the [ __ ] Second Story with
a duffel bag I've seen him do it before
I'm like bro chill out it's just a party
because he was there to sell sakus or a
pound of pounds of somebody
I remember that that's a whole other
story anyway
he said he was laying on motherfucker's
roofs because they were squad cars
everywhere because they know who the
[ __ ] lives there guns going off we'll
[ __ ] finally get your ass we're
finally coming to get you he said there
was helicopters there was a hell of
squad cars and he said I was laying on
roofs I was climbing in trees because I
know where he's at he's by The Creeks so
it's like bro you were out and about
like you're just escaping death and then
he ended up laying on his mom's roof
until the morning
and then he went on the run for like
three months and then
um he got the case dropped to like
misuse of a firearm
yeah I mean
anyway that fool's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
the guy his that his homie almost died
right after that [ __ ] wrecked his car
almost died like Karma hit that fool
crazy damn how do you know he had a gun
on him cause a fool had in his [ __ ]
hand when he was running across the law
and then he said he was like that the
guy was running because his car was down
the road he was like
nah and he said right he did the guy
looked and went no no no no no no no
like he was like oh my God he's about to
pop me because he didn't notice that my
homie was right out of his front door
like who is this who is this I'm a nah
I'm not gonna pop him because he's
shooting somebody in the back running
away he's going to prison forever it's
his murder he's like you know what no
and he said as soon as he had the guy
like looked back when he did he's like
oh he pulled his little [ __ ] ski mask
off uh I'd be so hurt it's like American
Horror Story or not uh American History
X that'd be so hurt damn remember he
told me the story I remember everything
so that's when my uncle John came home
from the Army and went [ __ ] your homie
that's why hmm so when he came back all
that had transpired Jesus Christ that's
why I was like your friend's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I explained what happened he
goes oh my God
what they were best friends
anyway my homie you got on probation for
that and caught another gun charge they
caught a [ __ ] 100 pound case they
caught a case with Oxys and it was all
because he had priors because of that
[ __ ] night
because the discharging a firearm
and he didn't want to tell him why
her he just said somebody broke in
somebody broken in my house no shooting
at him like why did you run away he was
like I was scared it was three months
later though yeah I remember so many
times I'd be sitting there before I was
really friends with him I'd be sitting
there and then his Ryan Ethan's dad
would get a call and like so and so he's
[ __ ] arrested we gotta go like all
right smoke Source all over your older
brother at it again but he was [ __ ]
18. yeah he's barely older than us he
just he always seemed like he was 30.
yeah because like how elevated
everything he was doing but this is the
same do that
was my only my best homie for like a
year and a half
when he was all [ __ ] up on oxy I was
trying to get him clean
I was trying to help him bro like well
you know the whole story but yeah that's
the same dude that's why I told my Uncle
John [ __ ] your connect don't ever call
him again
because he never went to jail nothing he
kept on being like a wee guy and
everyone knew like you're the one that
tried to Rob so-and-so right and that
was it for him I never heard from him
again he probably moved away like he
burned his name his name's gone damn
done especially with this fool is the
main guy you're [ __ ] done you're
lucky you know get killed but it's just
basketball
that's how it goes that's that is how it
goes I just found out some super creepy
[ __ ] about one of them yeah you told me
look at you should go on on that I'm not
going to but it just relates because
it's like [ __ ] man there's only that's
worse God damn that's worse bro I'm
sorry robbing robbing is some financial
[ __ ] what that is is uh
death in most jails instantly and
neighborhoods and neighborhoods like you
all he's got to die now yeah well keep
it at that you probably get what we're
talking about we'll keep it at that but
um sucks yeah it sucks bro it sucks but
I remember he told me that story what a
long rant sorry for that story but uh
yeah I just need to sell it because
that's why I told Uncle John [ __ ] off or
told him to tell his connect [ __ ] up but
yeah Uncle John proposed my aunt that
was that was 40 minutes ago sorry guys
with that being said let's have our
quick commercial break sponsored by us
what's up guys this episode is brought
to you by us we've been fortunate enough
to be asked to be speakers at Ted Talk I
know that sounds insane Marty does his
thing behind the scenes you know that
he's been doing the comedy the music
forever you know me I've been doing my
stuff on the internet but also I know
what I'm doing this business thing I got
on lock Marty's business he's got a lot
on top of us being high-ass dudes we
also know what we're doing so thank you
to Ted Talk for seeing that and seeing
the entrepreneurship and seeing the the
drive that we have the energy that we're
bringing to our fans our audience our
engagement that's what we're bringing to
Ted talk so this theme is the money
never stops okay this is what would you
do if all of your money was gone how are
you coming back to come up again I have
never had money my whole life until
recently so I know what I know what I
got to do I've been shut down at every
corner you guys know the story Marty
same thing hardships just trials and
tribulations things shutting you down
from achieving your goals but you kept
going and now we're here that's what
we're giving to the Ted Talk 307 South
Broadway that's a million dollar theater
go buy your tickets at ted.com go check
them out if you guys see us at the show
and you're there say what's up say hi to
us we're hyped we're hyped to see fans
at the Ted Talk that's going to be
badass I know we're not like making
money off tickets or anything we just
want fans to show up we want you guys to
come out there it's going to be on
YouTube for sure for everyone that can't
make the event but if you can come out
and say hi get ready this is the last
episode of the Year from Marty and I
guys thank you very much back to the
episode
guys look at that yeah God damn now
we're back you ready for these giveaways
yeah okay boom now we're back guys this
is what me and Mario decided to do uh
for Christmas giveaways we just we
realized this episode's not going to
come out on Christmas it's going to come
out after
it'd be kind of stupid to go hey by the
way on Instagram we gave way to bunch of
stuff here's the names
doesn't do anything so what we're doing
now if you are in this chat or say it's
two days later and you're watching this
video go over right here to Instagram
you have to have Instagram to do this
dope as usual podcast boom pops up dope
as usual podcast look for the most
recent post the most recent post we're
gonna post the second that this episode
airs so the second this episode airs on
Monday we're going to post it so you
know exactly what post we're going to do
a bunch of giveaways we have a podcast
but we also own a bunch of other [ __ ] we
do so much so we're gonna do giveaways
for every single company that we have so
starting with adobe's usual podcast what
we're gonna do just tag a friend on the
comment in the comments that's it we're
gonna pick a name for all these prizes
and you guys win
it's as simple as that the dope as usual
podcast if you can hit the follow button
that would be dope as hell we're not
doing this giveaway to like yo can we
get 5 000 followers Nah if you follow
that's dope we just wanna know that
would put us at 100. it would put us at
almost a hundred thousand we're about to
hit a hundred thousand or a hundred
thousand under 100 episodes which is
awesome uh but yeah follow that [ __ ] if
you want to that'd be sick if not
totally cool what I'm saying is leave a
comment all you gotta do is tag one
friend in the comments me and Marty in
three days we'll pick a winner so on
Wednesday we'll pick winners this is how
it's going to go ready the dope as usual
podcast whatever size you are that's
what you get one of every single thing I
don't know if we can be doing some
overlays we've got one shirt two shirts
three shirts I think we have some
sweaters in the back and shorts all
right we got sticker packs whatever the
value is I don't know what is everybody
limited edition too yes once they're
gone they're gone they're gone season
three [ __ ] is going to be insane we've
seen three shoots about three different
level different level of [ __ ] so that's
what we're gonna do guys so one of
everything for the dope as usual merch
right yeah like five four shirts sweater
shorts sticker packs so whatever this
beanie will sign some [ __ ] we're just
throw in extra [ __ ] thank you imaginary
Boombox we could have went and got
everything
but you know overlay Works overlay works
all right so that's just one prize and
remember if you tag a person you might
win one event you don't know what you're
winning all right we're gonna ask first
come first person to respond to the DM
like which one of these companies do you
want the gift card from like so be on it
all right so when this episode's out go
right after go right after the Instagram
I'm not gonna look at the contest I mean
the the giveaway until after the episode
anyway so don't think like oh I gotta
leave the episode to go on Instagram and
type you're fine I go through every name
don't worry I scroll the whole way down
to make sure no one's left out this is
what's gonna happen ready Number One
giveaway boom giveaway one dope as usual
that's every single thing that we have
to offer every single piece of merch we
have will come to you thank you very
much I don't know what the monetary
value is but it's like 200 it's like 250
bucks probably thank you all right
that's number one all right remember
go to Instagram I know I have to say it
again how do I enter let me get 700
comments in these comments of the
YouTube
this is not a giveaway on YouTube it's
on Instagram it's letting you know we're
announcing it now what we're giving away
here we are number two push trees
um I don't have many skus right now I'm
waiting for all my new stuff so I'll
give you 250 shopping spree whatever you
want you want bombs you want ashtrays
you want rigs whatever you want I call
is pretty [ __ ] far on post too yeah
it does do because we only have like
eight items in stock right now we
usually have like 30 but you know I
switch printers and stuff so whatever I
have you can have all right whatever
push tree [ __ ] you desire for 250 bucks
go for it if it comes out to like 260 or
whatever don't worry I got you all right
don't worry but don't be trying to get
over I'm like well 700 I'm like what was
it 250. all right we're small businesses
all right just because we make money on
certain things I mean every business is
crushing it we're trying okay so make
sure you get that black duffel too that
thing is it is it is hard
are you out of weed
I'm gonna pop this along there's three
Jets
there's three more oh yeah I remember
these things yeah so ready number one
dope as usual every single thing of
merch we have number two push trees 250
gift card credit whatever you want okay
ready for number three
number three is a brand new company that
I just started with my friends it's
called the rehab store
reupstore.com all right or rehab store
on Instagram the reupstore.com so what
we're doing is online headshot we got
anything from a five dollar tray to a
ten thousand dollar Darby rig Cactus
elbow glass [ __ ] whatever the hell
you call those crazy expensive ass rigs
all the way down to 40 bombs all right
we want it to be a bond on the budget
section nickel bag 10 sack a dub up to
like you're buying a pound of weed you
know it's something for everyone all
right we got dabbers for five bucks we
also have a dab set for 20 or we have
crazy ass bong for 200 or
that's our new company but we just
started it's like week three we're just
starting all right we haven't even done
the video the video comes out next week
to try to like let people know we have a
new site we haven't we have a new
Warehouse the whole Warehouse over there
so we're a small business okay so uh
we're gonna give like 150 credit anybody
that for rehabstore.com but if you're
not of age I can't give you credit to a
place that sells bongs so if you're not
of age you get some Visa gift cards or
something that you can go use all right
we just don't want to leave you out like
oh you're not 21 [ __ ] you no we'll just
give you something in replace that you
can use all right so 150 bucks to the
rehab store that's number three if you
there's a sick ass bong it's now yours
so we just want to say thank you guys
very much appreciate that sick congrats
on that too you got that up and running
behind the scenes
but yes it's up and going behind all
this other [ __ ] Warehouse is going shout
out to Jay and Tony because they're
keeping it running all right
they're doing all the orders we got
[ __ ] orders really cool it's really
cool guys we have electronic everything
Grinders everything you can think of if
you walk into a smoke shop we got you're
gonna have any secular Bart Simpsons
pieces like the Miami ziggies have
that'd be so cool I got some [ __ ]
cool pieces of stuff we're doing too say
a crazy ass artist has a thing for sale
we'll put it on our site and if we get
it sold we'll just take like five
percent commission or something come to
our shop our guarded gated ass shop and
make the transaction there and take the
videos take the video and [ __ ] be
safe when you're selling a twenty
thousand dollar bong that that's what we
wanted to make because Jay is all is the
heady guy he knows all the heady [ __ ] so
it's like yo Darby's coming to town he's
selling these two pieces like have them
do it here he's safe here we'll get some
cool content out of it take some
pictures of it
oh but if we make the sale like yo we
made the sale for you we'll take our
five percent commission come sell it
here change the money here so you're
safe like a broker like a broker yeah
that's what we'll do for crazy pieces
but if not I mean other than that we
still got you know our trays our little
bongs
we're a head shop right that's what
we're doing it's called The
reupstore.com Re-Up store on Instagram
check that [ __ ] out 150 credit that's
number three number four guys I talked
to the dopest all right yeah I talked to
the dopest and we're like you know what
what can we do and I'm like dude just
give someone a gift card and they can
get what they want not a set thing let
them get what they want so uh the fourth
and final giveaway
shout out to the dopashop.com it's a 500
we do we do we make more money on there
than we do push trees so we can afford
to give away more money
does that make sense yeah yeah so 500
bucks uh of any products you want if you
want 500 sharks do it if you want 50
pre-rolls get them you want some
[ __ ] gems hash house
real quick
gems Hash House you guys know my friend
Hash House you know hash rosin real hash
rosin the guy from the background of
last week's episode coughing his ass off
yeah we collabed with John his hashes
company with the dopa shop even though
he's part owner but he has his own
company too
this is Real Deal Hash House hash Raj
you know squished like squished Hash
Hash rods that I smoke in my videos
the same exact hash I smoke is inside of
these edibles
legally
under 0.3 per weight on Edibles is legal
we already got it run we I guarantee we
know what we're doing so yeah we really
it's all legal hash rosin Edibles in all
50 states
Hash House is legal in our Edibles in
all 50 states it doesn't even sound real
but I promise you it is I would not be
risking my freedom without making sure
I'm okay so this drop today on the
website with that being said if you want
500 worth of Hash House Edibles go do it
all right so that's what we're doing 500
gift card but if you're not 21 this is
it if you're not 21 I cannot give you a
gift card to the Dover shop because I'm
not risking
legality [ __ ] because I want to give you
free stuff sorry if you're not 21 and
you win the dopa shop one we'll just
give you a 500 like Visa card go do
whatever you want go buy your family
stuff whatever you want to do with it
tight but that's it ready dope is dope
as usual first one all geared every
piece of gear we have is yours number
two push trees 250 whatever we have in
stock that's yours 250 gift card boom
number three just started the company so
we're just new 150 on the reappstore.com
it's our online head shop okay number
four the dopa shop 500 or 500 gift card
whatever you want that is the prizes
that's what we're doing for
Christmas so thank you guys very much
really appreciate I know Christmas just
ended it was literally yesterday because
it's going to come on the 28th 26th yeah
it's Christmas was yesterday I'm sorry
that you know we missed it but we WE
Post on Mondays guys all right and this
is the last one of the year I am hyped
here we go shout out to you for
remembering all that [ __ ]
shelf not on the screen shock Ed
honestly
I was saying I'm like yeah
so thank you guys thank you guys Marty
with that being said we're back from our
commercial break we're back from our
giveaways remember dope as usual podcast
we will post the post you'll know
exactly what post to comment on because
we'll say this is the post to comment on
all right well we're going to talk we'll
show you it's on Instagram go leave tag
a friend in the comments that's how you
enter any of these giveaways we're just
gonna pick four people there it is four
different accounts get one of each thing
if you're feeling crazy drop your
favorite episode in the comments I
wouldn't mind seeing that we should do a
little flyer on the 31st what is your
favorite episode of the year yeah I like
that this is great or even like of the
month
I went to this I started to go make a
graphic like favorite guest of season
two it's too [ __ ] much like so much
everybody there's so much this year it's
crazy actually
we should still do it you know how you
do the Brady Bunch thing yeah that's
what I was trying to figure it's about
50 people
what if we do two slides
done for sure yeah
all right so Marty did you have anything
on the Christmas end
on my Christmas story times my Christmas
says were pretty simple they really were
you gotta imagine especially growing up
uh until Jamal came in the equation that
was just me when did you guys adopt him
he came he came in when I was like uh
11.
oh [ __ ] so you had by yourself for that
long oh yeah literally just it was just
me it was simple it was nothing too
[ __ ] crazy too special it was kind of
just
regular Baseline [ __ ] one I thought of
one funny Christmas memory when I first
got with April
that I kept having this I think I was
telling you I kept having this run of
like every time I try to get her
something people would like accidentally
ruin the surprise no you never told me
that oh yeah it happened like
comically for the first couple years was
being together really yeah like
different people different situations
and [ __ ]
but this is just this is like one of my
like
goes nowhere stories it's like a weren't
but it was like I was gonna shows
I was trying to like be creative and do
something else for her and because you
gotta keep in mind too her birthday is
right before Christmas his birthday is
December 4th the child was born oh
that's right that's right Jay-Z's
birthday too uh so yeah uh so I always
in this way yeah I mean you know the
April O'Neill the Cowabunga all the [ __ ]
yeah uh
so I was always like you know I gotta
get through the birthday and then go
right into Christmas like when I was
working my day job and [ __ ] we were
already always super broke
so I was like I planned a little trip
for us to go to the outlet mall
prime outlet mall right like in the
middle of nowhere in Pennsylvania
some [ __ ]
which in theory was like a good idea so
we get down there and I got us a hotel
and [ __ ] and I just remember feeling
like such a piece of [ __ ] because I got
us this hotel and then I took us to the
mall to like
for the trip but I only had like 25
dollars to give her the [ __ ] shot it
wasn't enough to buy anything
and before we left my my dad like I
don't even remember how he even like my
mom must have told him or something but
like right before we left he's like oh
you guys are getting ready going out to
the mall the outlet mall hit me right
before we walked out the phone it was
supposed to be a surprise
right in front of April oh
right in the hallway in my mom's house I
remember it it was like oh you know
hey yeah
[ __ ] like that does nowhere stories my
dad ruined the surprise it was just a
[ __ ] let down I think it would have
been maybe uh the next year where her ma
Got Me violently shit-faced Christmas
Eve
it was one of the two times her mom did
that and then we came back from their
Christmas party and I [ __ ] puked
everywhere right everywhere right next
to all the Christmas presents from just
sitting on the couches puke everybody
there it was just April then she had to
wrap all the Christmas presents by
herself because you threw up on them no
I puke right next to him I miss them I
didn't hit the presents it was right
next to him and I [ __ ] passed out and
she had to wrap up presents of grow up
she just shot me in the head
always better at christmasing than I am
oh yeah Rosie where's Rosie right now
it's Christmas [ __ ] yeah more kids
[ __ ] hate doing I always give
everybody a gift card and go do what he
want do what you want I gotta start
planning if I plan then it's different
like this year I plan a little uh-huh
and I'm playing like presents and [ __ ]
yeah I try to do that this year and
[ __ ] a certain band that we're fond
of kind of screwed me over with their
goddamn merch [ __ ] broccoli
broccoli metal band [ __ ] corn corn
website get it together we love you corn
but your website eats dick
Marty ordered and then they canceled it
without telling them they canceled
everything they didn't even they just
they're just refusing to ship the [ __ ]
they're like we'll give you your money
back [ __ ] give you the order it's been
two months I want my [ __ ] man it's been
two months and my mind it has oh yeah
come on corn we love you got me
scrambling before Barney was all
prepared no he made him look like he was
not
but it's okay we're gonna fight through
it
um
I got mad gas cards for everyone that's
a good idea my sister's a dick she
doesn't really like presents and what am
I gonna get her like well here dick you
can't say oh yeah I think
she doesn't like getting shits I'm like
sorry
[ __ ] and take it like genuinely she's
just like
or she just doesn't feel comfortable
like uh it's not comfortable she's just
like thanks I don't like I don't really
want those usually
not in that term it's more of like
you don't have to be the Grinch at the
beginning of the movie all the time
[ __ ] be the Grinch toward like you know
three fours in you're like kind of nice
and getting that like oh
yeah like me these people like oh my
family likes me like
I'm gonna go smoke a bowl in the garage
my mom's house
get out of this conversation just trying
to be nice man
we got our gas cards
it's got her mad money on gas card right
here don't pay for gas all year nice you
know I try to buy her a [ __ ] cars you
won't even let me do it
[ __ ] damn she spent all our [ __ ]
money she had on buying a new car I'm
like I would have [ __ ] bought it
what'd you get like a
RAV4 or some [ __ ] I don't know what it's
called it's like a SUV
when's it midnight when's it may be back
coming in
sitting at the port
they said we'll let you know when we
release it
we're [ __ ] doing donuts and [ __ ] bro
it's on it's on a ship it's in a cargo
cargo box
the car's been here for over a week and
a half in L.A it's at the port sitting
the guy's like I know you feel bad but I
got 15 Lambos on that part waiting all
sold just they said oh January 15th
we'll give you a call they've been there
since December like 8th
what the [ __ ] they're their own [ __ ]
judge Sheriff bro they don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah it's in the middle of that boat
oh we'll get you in a few weeks
you know how many boxes there are there
hundreds of them
and you have to Crane them out what if
it's the lowest one unless I try to get
the soda out at the grocery store like I
want those Ruby Red Squirt and it's on
there's 15 Pepsi's on it well let me
[ __ ] everyone else's day up and move
this and it falls over that's what
they're not gonna do for me so like no
we'll get to that 11 days oh I'm just
not even excited I'm just trying to like
does it come right to you or does it
have to go to a dealership it goes there
it goes to the dealership then I'm gonna
go pick it up yeah it should have zero
miles on it wow it hasn't been driven
yet
yeah
zero miles yeah it's got plastic it's
like completely wrapped still so I'm
gonna unwrap it wow I mean I'm gonna
tell John like don't let them unwrap it
I want to do it like I want to rip the
plastic off of everything
I still have all the plastic and Rosie's
cars on I forget to take it off every
time I look goes I can take that [ __ ]
off it's all the [ __ ] in the back all
the blue strips yeah yeah I keep
forgetting to take them all I'm like
[ __ ] it it protects it is John getting
some new show too
this was always getting new [ __ ] when
he's uh we'll be able to have him on the
show and he feels more comfortable the
reason we don't have John on the show
yet you know what let's not even talk
about it John will be on the show when
he's ready to be on the show and then
when he is he'll be able to talk about
everything he's gonna be [ __ ] outside
I threw it trying to talk [ __ ] about my
sister thank you oh yeah John it's gonna
be epic
um see I'm just waiting in the car just
waiting but anyway yeah I was just want
to buy a car a dick I bought her some
[ __ ] Gucci shoes that look just like
the van she only wears
she goes oh [ __ ] yeah
uh a worm but nobody knows what they are
you're gonna wear them when nobody knows
what the Gucci symbol is you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's in a hundred years
somebody she's like I'm never gonna wear
these Gucci shoes like [ __ ] I was just
trying to do some bougie [ __ ] because
you don't like bougie [ __ ] I thought
it'd be cool you [ __ ] through your flat
van slip-ons but the Gucci print look
cool they look cool I could have got you
Vans but I mean you have Vans let's try
to be nice something special it's like
yeah I don't think she's I don't think
she's taking another box yet damn she's
just not down with any of the any of
that I guess I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
just saying like
oh stop pulling the wall it's not a
razor she's at least she didn't do that
she was like oh it's uh
damn bro I wore [ __ ] Vans that's the
kind of look she gave me I was like I
know you were Vans [ __ ] so do I uh-huh
this [ __ ] is still cool though still
cool
dick
um but yeah I don't know what we're
talking about man John gave me a whole
[ __ ] class he gave me a consultation
on luxury cars and [ __ ] and his
experiences that [ __ ] was invaluable of
course she says the best one yeah out of
all these cars he's like he's like I'm
one with the lambo and I'm driving the
lambo I am the lambo but the Porsche is
a driver's car yeah he should do this
you better be on your [ __ ] in that Lambo
like you you cannot
oh sup bro yeah like no you can't do
anything no you can't even smoke a joint
in that car you cannot do anything but
Fight for Your Life in that car which
why I don't like it it's too scary I've
driven it driven it once and I hate it
it's so much responsibility damn near
bust your kneecap open on the Tesla no I
thought it was in the Blue Lamp it was
the Tesla oh the screen the screen what
into the dip of my knee where there's no
bone
and it felt like it popped it out of
place oh man I did it in the lambo too I
when the lambo the [ __ ] camera was
hit me in the [ __ ] mouth yeah
recording it almost popped me
that [ __ ] takes off so violently I don't
that's just too much responsibility
it's way too much responsibility I can't
wait to talk about cars and [ __ ] over
here I'm sorry guys it's like
unrelatable as [ __ ] but it's fun if your
car guys relatable as hell I just think
it's cool anybody who wants a nice shot
I think it's cool yeah it's [ __ ]
awesome I was taking pictures of it and
[ __ ] yeah it's not like yo I got 17
Rolexes it's more like oh my God I like
that watch a lot
this is the [ __ ] we wanted when we were
on the [ __ ] porch exactly when I was
sitting in the house I never won a
jewelry but I was like yo when I was
delivering pizza I saw that white
Mercedes for sale I went oh my God he
wants 10 bands for eight thousand dollar
car [ __ ] him and I didn't buy it and he
was smoking a cigarette when I walked up
and he was smoking a cigarette in it it
was his daily driver but he was selling
it I was like a bad advice about this
Karma get out of here but I remember I
drove away like one day I'm gonna have
that [ __ ] [ __ ] it was the oh it was
the the 50 Cent one yeah it was the 50
Cent one and it had it wasn't
convertible though but it was that model
and I'm Marissa all I
50 Cent
hell yeah I'm gonna get that car one day
[ __ ] hype dude just fun stuff cool
stuff
motivational things for myself too I
every time someone's dope [ __ ] happens
they go damn [ __ ]
um because the person that used to do
that [ __ ] heavy was Michael John like
every time something happened you call
me bro what the [ __ ] like when we call
it you're like he would call me like
that so it's like [ __ ] it's weird
somebody's actually happy for cool
things like oh yeah just that fool so
stoked
it's crazy because he's like the guy
behind the carry you never see his ass
yeah and everybody knows everything
about him uh-huh and he was like damn
that's crazy when you talk about the
time like yeah you smoked crack
everyone knows you smoke crack with me
you got me you're still crack you hassle
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
um where are we at
damn 106 good timing yeah okay here we
go oh and shot off for last week's
episode of support on that oh [ __ ]
fulcrum episodes by the way thank you
for saying that
I'm gonna say I want to say some [ __ ]
watching that kid
talk how his brain just said it was
amazing and I don't mean kid because
he's younger I mean I say everybody kid
I do that [ __ ] all the time and watching
him just do it freely I was like
I [ __ ] with this dude so much more than
I thought I was going come another show
like this with like older dudes you know
he wasn't timid to be him at all no he
was chill I'm just saying like
he stood up and just froze I do that
[ __ ] to Rosie in the house
in the most awkward position and [ __ ]
that I'm do
while I'm mid-shot chopping vegetable
but I'll just sit there until she's like
dude all right yeah sometimes be like a
minute and I'll stop like when he's
Frozen go bro I do that to Rosie
constantly I [ __ ] would love this dude
because I'm like yo you're a weirdo too
I do stupid [ __ ] just like that it's
made me like
I [ __ ] like this guy you know what I
mean it just I don't know so shout out
to fulcrum all right shout out to
everybody out there
um the positivity and real quick we've
had Stevo on here we've had Dr Drew
we've had major names on this show that
pull audiences and all that stuff great
I just want to let everybody know
this past month
we've had nothing but YouTubers all of
you guys are pulling more people than
these famous household names and I'm not
putting down any money stevos or
anything I'm just saying like look at
that Idol Steel's a [ __ ] celebrity
he's the man
and you guys are pulling these numbers
maybe even slightly higher
that's a fan base
you know I'm saying like look at your
fan base when I go on other people's
shows and something means like damn you
got a lot of people these comments hi to
me that's the fan base bro people we
connect with them because they're us and
we are them
so when I say like Goblin's been here
Eric Khan's been here dudo's been here
folkman's been here in a row watching
their fans fluctuate and come to our
[ __ ] enough watching the fans flock to
that episode and go yo good [ __ ] it's so
dope to see so that's why I want
everybody out there to look content
creators are the new
step in the door
is that does that make sense like it's
in your Bo Burnham is it a hilarious
comedian respected comedian like other
comedians look at him like oh he's a
stand-up
that fool started off on Vine I remember
him making stupid ass little six second
Clips he made them and realized oh
people laugh I have a following let me
hone the craft of Comedy look what he's
doing all right we doing the Wii [ __ ] I
never talked on camera I didn't know how
to talk on camera I tried story started
honing in on story time now we talk for
a [ __ ] living this is what we do
it just takes time and knowing like oh I
really liked that I never once went I
can get paid off talking never I went I
like this a lot and then people like
you're good at this you captivating me
story like really and I watch I'll find
I'll watch back the editing I used to
edit myself before I met you like yo
that was pretty [ __ ] funny like I'm
I'm involved in the story and I told
this [ __ ] wow okay I can see how people
like this and then you get more like
yeah I like doing it's like when a
basketball player realizes he's like
good at basketball you know I mean I'm
like wow of course this is fun this is
fun and people love it this is what I'm
doing you can just talk yeah so that's
what I wanted when you brought the
fulcrum like look kante creation he's
doing his thing building up his
following Eric Goblin dude all these
dudes are doing their thing and you can
do it too is what I'm trying to tell you
a phase is from phase Reigns from like
in Canada ddg was from where Flint
[ __ ] Michigan Michigan
all right not Flint Pontiac Pontiac
Michigan
guys
he's got albums on the top number number
top 10 right now some of those songs
were charting so high he started off as
a content creator realized he liked
doing rap mice making music look what
he's doing still makes content creation
because that's his foundation
but this music is where you try and
Elevate I made content it's my
Foundation I love it we're making this
podcast because this is what I want to
do
there's so many things you could
possibly do and vocals like music oh I
like Andre curry [ __ ] let me put my
content integration come up and my music
will come up too Eric I don't know what
Eric went he I don't know like his other
hobbies are but God but I don't know
either but look what they're doing with
their fan base
they're building their fan base up to
monetize essentially off of what they do
different business Endeavors that you
get into and we're all in the same space
but there's room for everyone
yeah
I don't like that [ __ ] when people like
oh no I ain't trying to [ __ ] with that
fool if he gets bigger than me like
somehow it goes now how it works it
doesn't work that way someone's always
gonna be better
always gonna happen who gives a [ __ ] as
long as you're happy
right now do you like Tupac yeah I love
Tupac does that mean you're not gonna
listen to another rapper Because You
Love Tupac it's just like how like Rogan
did it and then like brought his guys up
don't control different you love all
their shows love them all
but they all could come together too and
be strong as [ __ ] and they're all strong
on their own
just like all the YouTuber dudes like I
do my thing they do their thing we all
come together it's fun it's dope
I don't know that's the way I see it so
yeah thank you for bringing that up so
that CNF will just do stupid [ __ ] I'm
like dude I do stupid [ __ ] like that
love this guy and we got tons of
comments about the ice and the piss
trough oh yeah it is Oakland A's I was
right well yeah but it's to splashback
wash splashback someone said it stops
with splashback oh okay what'd you read
that the piss is melting the ice so it's
kind of washing the down the drain with
the piss so it's water and piss being
drained yes
the smell a lot of comments on it though
and I saw I read a lot of comments
um Jesus
go bills by the way throwing [ __ ]
cool bills by the way I'm just throwing
that one out there oh my God let's go
um
[ __ ] good [ __ ] all right
um this is the last episode of the year
and this is the first time on Earth
we're gonna hit hour and a half yeah
it will happen today all right let me
end you off with this little piece
story
when I started dating Rosie
I was
just stopping the weed no no no I was
still selling weed I stopped selling
weed when Instagram started taking off a
little bit sorry
the weed was slowing down so violently
bad
I remember there was one day I looked at
my cabinet like six pounds of the
purpliest perfect form packs
every nug two grams every nug was a
picture magazine I had Sour Diesel
pristine pack I had a lamb's bread
perfect I had like six pounds of all
these [ __ ] strains I couldn't get rid
of a sack
couldn't get rid of a 10 sack like
I have these people in my phone
and then it slowly like stopped selling
I I sold we need to a lot of people that
sold weed like this full sells a pound
this full size cues just full breaks
down the ounces right here here here
here here to me I don't give a [ __ ] like
yo you four Zips uh all right I'll do
that four more times that's a pound
perfect don't care if you only bought a
cube bro I'm breaking it down anyway and
I had fire oh one was a cherry pie pack
I remember looking at it like
and I can't get rid of this there was a
time I was so broke
you got to remember if no one's buying
the weed
and I'm smoking weed
I'm not gonna get anything
there was a point where like a month and
a half I wasn't getting rid of [ __ ]
there was a time I remember the time I
text a few people like yo let me know
when you need something and I went
I'm playing offense here God damn yeah I
was like dude am I asking people to buy
that's interesting
it's felt like this is not the way to do
it
and I hate this
me Rosie started dating right
Nero started dating and I remember I was
so I went from having constant money to
just being so it was the only time that
I had that I wasn't selling a lot of
weed for like for like six months
straight there was no like [ __ ] was bad
I don't know how it happened but it went
back to normal anyway
to start dating and I remember I had
eight like almost 19 in cash besides
like eight pounds of weed damn
I remember that I remember like I got
like 20 bucks are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me
I was down I never saved money I was a
[ __ ] idiot
I had no money anyway I had like 19
bucks in my pocket I remember
and I was just started dating Rosie I'm
like yo let's get food and that's back
before I started eating healthy [ __ ] get
food make six dollars could get you all
the food in the world when you go to KFC
McDonald's and all like that's enough
for two people to eat so I remember
going to KFC I'm like all right cool
just like you did at the [ __ ] outlet
mall 25 I was pulled a Half Baked six
dollars
spare some change thank you remember are
you [ __ ] stealing on the uh eating
the hot dog let's walk like can we get a
cab that's how I felt like
I have no [ __ ] Rosie has a job
she has money but I'm not about to ask
Rosie can you pay for it oh the worst
[ __ ] no I'm doing that [ __ ] I asked you
so we're going to her apartment I'm
leaving my house going to her apartment
we're going to KFC parking lot I mean
the drive-through and now she comes out
to like 11 and on my head I'm like oh
damn okay okay and then she gets a text
like oh can we get Monica something I'm
like yeah of course her roommate
and it was
1840 something I remember I went
19 thank God and I would thank you and I
got it and we get back to the house and
they forgot one of my things and was
like
I'm so bored you forgot one of my oh my
God
and if I wasn't into this day I'd be the
richest guy in the world with all that
weed nobody wanted the Wii for some
reason I could not get rid of it ever
just buying mid-packs outdoor packs
it was just it went bad it went bad
that sucked a lot so that first year I
was with Rosie that led into Christmas
is why I brought that up I tell
backstory so [ __ ] much I'm sorry
leads me into the Christmas story
first Christmas that throws Christmas
first Christmas with Rosie I can't even
speak was so scary
I was like yo it's the first time in my
life I'm not balling out of control
after 18 like I had to do whatever you
want like I got money what am I doing
I'm selling work at the pizzas but I got
too much money right here
I had so much money all the time like it
doesn't matter I got my nose he'll do it
and then it went to oh you're broke and
John had just went missing
my dealer my oh yeah sorry I'm not
calling John anymore my dealer had just
went missing
two and a half months into me and Rosie
dating
so as soon as I couldn't get rid of weed
I had no more connect um
I remember how hard it was with Note
with not being able to get rid of weed
but I remember I had weed what happened
all the people that were normally buying
from you they just fell off or they
found a different place well they found
different people that were cheaper bro
my [ __ ] was such top shelf fire Pat they
called them Triple A packs they were AAA
packs from Humboldt County and Humboldt
County because my dealer was getting
them he would go up there and get like
60 packs 80 pack and bring them back
give me 10 or 20. and I'd go get rid of
my [ __ ] come I mean I was [ __ ]
killing it for a while
and then he went missing
and then I really was [ __ ]
and this is like October
oh no sorry sorry six months later it's
the it's the year me and Rosie sorry
mirrors are date in November it's the
year the next year he went missing in
like mid mid to the middle of the Year
middle of the Year me Rose anniversary
is in November and that Christmas
remember I was like after six months it
was I was broke that six months LED
right into Christmas this is the reason
why I'm bringing the story up sorry
timeline I'm trying to make sure I'm
right on point so it makes sense in my
head
the years are hard to remember [ __ ] like
which year it was or what happened when
it happened he went missing and I and
that's what I meant stinky Dan that
blocked all my punches that's why I met
sticky Dan because my dealer went
missing if you watch my dealer story
time it leads right into that that's how
that happened
excuse me
I had no money at all and it was
Christmas guys and I remember
have you ever like looked around like
you're at Walgreens getting like some
drink and go
I think I can make Christmas work at
this aisle oh this Walmart Oh Walgreens
knows what they're doing Walgreens has
things for this kid and they got
something I can give for my grandma for
eight dollars and there's a 12 thing
over there for another kid I think I can
make it work here that's [ __ ] true
yeah so I was in Walgreens like
I don't know what to do me and Rosie
don't buy each other Christmas presents
ever we've no I don't think we ever
really have really even today I can get
[ __ ] for Rosie she'll get [ __ ] for me we
don't really get anything for each other
we just want to hang out if I can not be
bugged and hang out Rosie we're winning
and uh
even when we were poor we never got [ __ ]
for each other because we always got
[ __ ] for everyone else we didn't have no
money left over
like that's the [ __ ] way it worked
but this year I mean we're not broke
this year it's just dude we she got a
new car I'm gonna get a car
when she wants shoes you buy shoes if I
wanted a new shirt I'll buy a shirt so I
don't really want [ __ ] anything it's
neither does she like what can you give
me for Christmas Rosie give me 50 60
pounds [ __ ] more better in shape no
all right leave me some vitamin store
that's what I told my whole family get
me vitamin shop gift card if you really
want to give me something for Christmas
give me a [ __ ] gift card vitamin shop
because I'm that's all I'm gonna be
doing next year is trying to get [ __ ]
in shape I don't want anything I already
bought clothes those clothes barely fit
let me make them fit better just give me
Vitamin Shoppe [ __ ] that in the trainer
that's all I want to do yeah yeah so
that I remember that first year I'm
going through Walgreens like what am I
gonna do and then Rosie tells me like I
don't really want [ __ ] I'm like oh my
God
[ __ ] God if we buy something for each
other it was always like mid-January
when we like re-upped our money somehow
and got to Rosie's such a [ __ ] down
ass fool she never once complained about
being poor ever not one time it was
it's kind of odd thinking about it like
we were broke as [ __ ] for like nine
years straight
plus two yeah yeah for once
nothing we watched Sex in the City
during quarantine that's the only reason
we ever bought our first pair of
designer shoes I went and bought them
for my yo this [ __ ] is talking about
crazy [ __ ] and I'm like it really
matters Carl's like oh that's something
something from this collection go oh
that's cool it's like loading cars like
dancing 66 count oh good [ __ ] girl see
[ __ ] like that's the [ __ ] what the
hell that's a this this designer this
year this model 1960 like damn you
[ __ ] done Rosie knows all of
that [ __ ] as a kid her her that's what
she did look at magazine she was a
little girl like a girly girl so she's
like dude I've never been before this
[ __ ] it's cool to look look at that look
at that purse and now she's got them so
it's cool but she never once went oh
let's see about can I get a pair like
[ __ ] report never once ever did
Rosie ever act weird
and yeah she's [ __ ] awesome so that
first Christmas was bad bro I didn't get
her [ __ ]
first Christmas we didn't get each other
anything
I can't remember but I'm pretty sure
same [ __ ] boat because I quit my job
as soon as me and April got together so
I then became broke as [ __ ]
for about a year until we were about to
have a kid
it was all bad dude that's where it was
all bad and that brings me up to the
last part of this last Christmas
I finally had ten thousand dollars
legally like saved in my bank account
and I spent five bands on Christmas and
I remember I looked at Rosie I'm like
you know we spent half the money we have
on Christmas
but we usually like oh we had 600 bucks
we have 12 people we got to get for how
can we make it work and now it's like
you got 12 people we get for how much do
we spend at the end like we don't give a
[ __ ] we now that we have if I have 800
and I need to spend 600 on people I'm
gonna do it
you know what I'm saying like oh I got
it covered fine it's fine I got you guys
well bye now I'm getting better I'm like
I'll go buy yesterday I bought glasses
when I went on one of these classes
I I didn't do it like we're gonna do
content do this and I just went I like
this class
you know I mean like I know I got why
all that [ __ ] in the clock but most
of it's more like oh take a picture it
looks sick it takes photos in it blah
blah and it's just it's just weird
buying yourself [ __ ] so
um yeah so we had 10 bands we spent five
and then this year we went crazy as hell
[ __ ] it I'm just really excited I'm
[ __ ] hyped as hell to finally be able
to do [ __ ] and not go how much money is
left I know you probably a lot of you
relate to this my whole life into in
with Rosie counting the groceries like
that's six dollars
counting up your whole grocery cart like
okay that's 96 that's like 98 bucks but
I got 100 I [ __ ] put this back put this
back put this back [ __ ] can't make that
[ __ ] okay let's put this all this part
back let's think of more like I I hate
that feeling like my mom did that [ __ ]
every time I would my mom would be
pushing a cart I'd be counting [ __ ] I
remember I was like five just like oh
that's not we have enough money [ __ ] and
my mama I was wondering if she would
send me the car she was using food
stamps she was embarrassed and she
always made me sit in the car first off
you're sending me to the car lot girl
she's gonna get robbed I'm [ __ ] six
my sister's seven
but she was embarrassed of using food
stamps and [ __ ] but I remember I'd be
counting like we don't got no money this
sucks
and it's the first time my life where I
went and got presents for people like I
don't care I don't care how much [ __ ]
yeah good [ __ ] it's just a different
feeling this year it's very like
awesome and you guys got your [ __ ]
house done essentially
so next year is going to be your
[ __ ] a horse unwrapping a horse
a unicorn
like you know to me like you guys are
that's me and Rosie next year it's like
we're not going to bunch of presents we
just got a house that's us we're gonna
flip next year we're like no we're
buying a house [ __ ] you eat a
dick I'll give you a gift card you know
I mean this year I'm like yo is the last
year we're gonna be able to do it with a
couple years left of no kids we don't
have a house yet we can do this this
year and like buy [ __ ] for people that
we want to get so that's that's the end
of the Christmas part you guys are
crushing that's crazy to watch I'm
excited
thank you sir
we just moved
the house tour just came out two days
ago I'm moving away I'm done I'm moving
out of the spot we just finished the
video the day you sent me the video like
video's done and go
I'm moving I just said told the building
I'm out
but it's okay I'm [ __ ] moving guys
I'm over this place spent too much money
for [ __ ] out to work so the penthouse
that I really like American Psycho done
I'll be out next month
stupid house
actual house and it's unbelievably fat
for cheaper than what I paid oh [ __ ] I
didn't realize that nice I'm not gonna
say prices wise but it's
it's a pound of fire pound cheaper okay
all right
so bracing on where you live you can
stitch on how much that is but as a
pound of really good California weed
that I would buy right now it's a pound
away cheaper for a house with a pool and
a yard and a garage it's a house it's a
house four bedroom house
first of all for a pound of cheaper than
my apartment
Burbank and glendale's too expensive
it's overpriced yeah I'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] that [ __ ] plus I I
park in a parking garage in my bar and I
have that new car [ __ ] up yeah oh yeah I
have to oh from my apartment get in the
elevator go to the lobby walk 40 50
yards
80 yards that's not 40 yards
elevator again walk another 80 100 yards
too many cars in space and if I'm
pulling that car in there I'm gonna be
real pissed coming out and someone's
parked in my spot or someone open their
door into my [ __ ] like I can't do it no
more I can't I gotta get a house I'm
over it I wasn't planning on it but I
didn't have 50 days of no AC 50 out of
the first 70 days I lived there there's
no AC during the heat wave they come to
me some rare whatever I don't care I
just want the
then the first two weeks of December
there's no heat and then for a week my
water didn't get hot and then my washer
didn't work for five days
bro come on you're the first tenant in
the whole building so it's like you
should have been prepared for me sorry
um that's the Christmas thing I wanted
to end it with we start me and Rosie the
first Christmas ever was so bad
and now we're finally like 10 years
later finally doing good enough to like
yo just whatever they want whatever we
can do just get it for them
I'm stoked uh my mom's gonna see this
after but I my mom I got her [ __ ] a
trip wherever you want to go no Chef
where do you think she's gonna want to
go
um I might just make it easier and get a
resort for her get a resort place like
the week or whatever like yo
it's all paid for just [ __ ] drive
that she gets the pig where yeah where
do you think she's gonna pick New York
oh [ __ ] she wants to go hella bad that's
why I ain't flying the snow he had to
wait till March New York for me you can
go now I ain't going now yeah yeah and
uh
yeah he's about to hook my [ __ ] kids
up they're about to [ __ ] their pants
found a PS5 which is hard as hell to get
in California yeah found a PS5 I was
like yo I got this PS5 my homies like
yourself to somebody I'm like I'll ask
somebody if they want it and you were
talking about getting like
I just know when I got your kids before
Christmas I got the girls like other
like less [ __ ] and [ __ ] because you
mainly cam mainly gonna be like no no
it's gonna be me and him so that's why I
was like I felt bad at going hey girls
this is yours too so it's like the kids
and then I got we got the girls but
they're gonna be so
hyped the Madden the basketball the GTA
the [ __ ] guys let us know the best PS
what is the drop it drop in the comments
leave your five most fun games that an
eight-year-old could play all the way up
to our age yes all right Doom probably
not probably not Elden ring probably not
for for Cam he's a sports kid he's
active as [ __ ] he's a prisoner workout
he does prisoner workouts in his room
and he's a child that's true he's one of
those guys so leave us some [ __ ] like
you can play FIFA 2K racing Spider-Man
Spider-Man
yeah Uncharted I guess I could just tell
you hey on chart it's really tight okay
but you guys you guys are the gamers
leave a little list in the comments
please leave a little list in the
comments that's gonna be some funny [ __ ]
if I video me and him playing that's
gonna be [ __ ] hilarious being him
battling on 2K oh yeah dude oh yeah yeah
so yeah your kid's gonna be what games
you guys get all those ones I just
mentioned oh you bought them well we got
like FIFA Madden NBA I think we have GTA
got a couple of controllers pretty sure
yeah bro Christmas day's gonna be yes
oh you're you're not a Mexican family
you do Christmas day yeah why do you
even ask
Mexican [ __ ] oh I don't know why every
major family I ever met does Christmas
Eve really I've done Christmas my entire
existence yeah now it kicks off when you
wake up [ __ ] that [ __ ]
my grandma would
let us open like all presents on
Christmas Eve end of the morning oh [ __ ]
we go hard on Christmas Eve damn oh we
used to go hard that's why I'm like
that's why I want to buy my Grandma's
old house in Merced
because it's you're allowed to build oh
this is my plan real quick my grandma
Dolores we went that was Christmas
that's where you go oh no we're 1 30.
anyway I want to buy our house so I
could uh uh build a nice house in the
back we can stay there and then while
you guys ready to open presents
Grandma's old house and we walk in and
be like oh this is Grandma's house from
when we were kids it's the same no one
lives in here in the year [ __ ] that's
our [ __ ] anyway sorry done hour 30. oh
you did it
hey that was the quickest story I ever
told yeah grandma oh Bob get the house
anyway done
let's go guys all right PlayStation kids
about to be hyped Christmas is about to
happen
about to crush this [ __ ] here
ooh Ted Talk me and Marty went over
right before we started
he's he's a he's a word Smith
the first line I went all right now I'm
Gonna Change like I understand what I
had my [ __ ] because that's a way better
Direction so that's what we're doing
guys
um thank you so much Marty anything else
you want to say last episode of the Year
thank you of the year not the season
thank the community I'm grateful I'm
fired up I'm just happy to be here I'm
gonna give it my all the whole team is
that's it it's about to we're just
getting started with this show
yes and I'm on day five of waking up
early and taking my vitamins every day
let's go
next year is about to be hard
designing the day that's what you told
me design your day
shout out to Rob your dick for that one
all right guys this has been 2022 right
2022 we've been in this room the whole
year last episode of the Year excuse me
this is right after Christmas so we
won't see you till after New Year oh my
God
foreign
drive safe
the Uber charge might be a couple
dollars more
during New Year's don't drink and drive
all right I have a lot of friends that
have died in car crashes a lot of them
maybe a couple were you know intoxicated
they could still be here so don't be one
of the people that misses out on next
year you know what I'm saying be chill
don't drink and drive call that Uber
that's why it's there get a taxi walk
home or sleep on someone's couch don't
drink and drive it's Christmas time
everybody's back in town wants to go
hang out with their friends they haven't
seen see them next year by not drinking
and driving also that's the one thing
you need to get across everybody's gonna
be hyped up doing their thing don't be
don't be stupid and dead
or in jail
all right I was looking for my [ __ ]
police sirens but all I came up with was
hey yo
drinking don't be driving hey yo yo yeah
that's the cops behind you getting
pulled over hey yo hey yo so please be
safe don't drink and drive end of the
year season two's coming to an end get
say bye to the room we only got a couple
more episodes in this room and it's over
it's weird it's brand new the set's
looking dope everything's gonna look
sick as hell new everything Ted Talk
January 6th all right you might have saw
our little ad response about us
um guys thank you so much for everything
thank you for
we told Mario before we stopped like if
we stop doing weed [ __ ] like we talked
about earlier if we stopped doing weed
[ __ ] we'd still have this following with
our words and the podcast and the
hangout and the vibe so
thank you
like this stands on its own this is our
[ __ ] I have somebody before we start
it's not the dope as yellow podcast this
is the dope as usual podcast this is our
[ __ ] it's not
people don't come here like yo I want to
just hear Thomas talk like [ __ ]
us we're having conversations we're
doing things me and Marty were
it's different all right it's not just
like I I talk to the camera like we're
talking we're doing [ __ ] it's a Vibe
it's the garage conversation you have
with your homies
that's what we're going for and that's
what we try to disarm every guess like
no you can hang out here and just be
yourself
so thank you for being yourself at home
and letting us be ourselves to talk
about the stupidest [ __ ] we've ever done
and a lot of losses and a lot of cool
wins and I hope the wins make you guys
stoked like for yourselves when I see my
like I said when we see other people
crushing it like it makes me like good
[ __ ] I want to step it up now I need to
catch up I want to step it up not every
everybody's level not everybody's like
I'm not gonna step it up and be better
editor I could I mean if I dedicated
years but why like I know what I'm doing
my strengths like you said what do you
what value do you bring to the table
like what do you bring to your table and
if you don't have a table make your own
[ __ ] table like we did and there we
go wow oh yeah that's good that was a
good that was good Jesus Christ I was
like oh I gotta write that down that was
good thank you guys so much for being
here for Marty O'Neill and I thank you
so much this is a dope as usual podcast
have a dope ass day
end of the year damn
I'm hyped now what time is it
foreign
[Music]